[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم قوه اسرائيليه خاصه
تقتل اربعه شبان فلسطينيين في جنين وتدفع
بتعزيزات الى المنطقه وسط اشتباكات مع
مقاومين وكتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس
تقول ان احد الشهداء هو القيادي فيها نضال
خازن وان شهيدا اخر هو يوسف الشريم من
كتائب القسام بعد كشف تفاصيل عمليه مجدو
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يقول خلال تفقده
الحدود مع لبنان ان عمليه كبيره احبطت
وتوعد بتوجيه ضربه للمسؤولين عنها في حين
نفت اليونيفيل علمها بعبور اي شخص للخط
الازرق وقالت انها لم تتلقى طلبا رسميا
اسرائيليا للتحقق من حصول تسلل عقب يومين
على الحادثه البنتاجوني ينشر صورا لعمليه
اعتراض المقاتل الروسيه للمسيره الامريكيه
فوق البحر الاسود واشنط ان قرار الاسقاط
اتخذ على اعلى المستويات في الكريملين
بينما اكدت روسيا ان اي استهداف لطائراتها
في الاجواء الدوليه يعد اعلان حرف
بريطانيا تحضر استخدام تيك توك على
الهواتف الرسميه للوزراء وموظفي الدوله
وانباء عن ضغوط امريكيه على ملاك التطبيق
الصينيين لبيعه في حين قالت بيجين ان
واشنطن لم تقدم اي دليل يثبت وانه يعرض
الامن القوميه الامريكيه للخطر وطلبتها
بالتوقف عن نشر معلومات خاطئه الى اللقاء